[Applaudissements]
le quart d'heure sans pitre et je
propose qu'on démarre par matt singer
aller ailleurs apprendre à l'énergie
musique on rigolera c'est vrai qu'on a
des dards cas les chérit le succès
petite grimace singer énorme succès
vendredi 6,6 millions de téléspectateurs
32,5 de part de marché 48 6% sur les
ménagères il était largement en tête des
audiences ce schéma stinger était numéro
1 avec 6 6 millions
derrière il y avait le poids des
mensonges sur france 2 une redif un
france 2 il y avait un nouveau programme
sur tf1 ils sont dit tiens si on mettait
une rediff
quand les génies de fond de sortie il
faut les signaler les vieilles canailles
c'est un match mais parce que quand il
ya des gens qu'on est un génie on le
monde voilà les décanat l'histoire d'un
concert mythique sur france 3 donc voilà
ça plutôt pas mal marché de la gueule il
ya des boules c'est bien c'est une série
sur le voile américaine mais il y avait
une enquête quantique c'est ce que j'ai
regardé sur arte une enquête quantique
alors ça voilà ça c'est ce que j'aime
alors tf1 élargi d'or de la soirée 6
célébrités se sont affrontés alors c'est
des célébrités donc qui sont déguisés
c'est ça en fait le thème était fin
débourser beaucoup d'argent pour masquer
singer puisque chaque prime coûterait
environ 900 mille euros exactement neuf
cent mille euros pour le prennent alors
le succès petit dru où vous pose la
question on va vous faire un petit
résumé et vous nous dites juste après
c'est particulier mais qui sont alors il
ya une prestation qui a surpris tout le
monde c'est celle du panda on va
rappeler donc c'est des pandas des trucs
des gens qui chantent
on pensait tous qu'il s'agissait d'un
mec dans le costume mais dès les
premières notes on s'est tous mis à
douter
vous allez penser ce que ça peut durer
ou pas ceux qui pensent ça peut durer
oui ici ceux dont la non particulière
ouais je montre et
d
[Musique]
je chantais
total va donc c'était arcade avec une
chanter et à la fin il y en a 1 éliminée
et donc on sait de qui il s'agit voilà
et c'est une star alan moore denis soir
donc le principe donc il est sain je
voulais 10 des people qui ont loupé le
casting de danse avec les stars chantent
dans des costumes de carnaval
alors c'est vrai que les costumes je
vous dis pas je pense que ça va
cartonner
je vous le dis parce que et tous les
enfants ou qui fait moi j'ai une copine
a eu des enfants ils étaient scotchés
devant après voilà quand à plus de 20
ans tu te dis bon c'est une petite
terrasse mais sinon ça va c'est vrai que
les costumes sont bien mais dès qu'une
mascotte entre en plateau le jury en
fait ils en font pas un poil qu'on fait
non mais c'est un truc de ouf on l'aura
qui montre une consigne regardez
[Applaudissements]
mais génial oh la la qu'est ce que c'est
beau
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
non
paul theroux
[Applaudissements]
voilà
trois magnifiques
olalala l'ipo jour règle mais qu'est ce
tu déposes
[Applaudissements]
mieux
oui j'ai envie c'est un moment horrible
je m'en sers pas si simple excuse moi
c'est un moment horrible art déjà aucun
intérêt parce que nous fallait costumes
passé c'est très bon enfin la semaine
prochaine guerre le même costume oui il
y avait un costume c'est le personnage
phare d'un vrai que c'est toujours le
même personnage
ah oui ah ouais merde donc là n'y a plus
d'effet de surprise voilà et surtout ses
avocats le thème s'ils ne le sont pas
parce que c'est une bande enregistrée
devraient s'ils font semblant de chanter
une étude énergétique oui les sinistres
en studio donc avec des effets donc pour
tous on est belle voix et sert à ses
nuits et le public qui ont fait déjà pas
le jury qui ont fait des tonnes
alors qu'ils sont en fuite qui sont sur
le coup qui sont induits en train de
chercher franchement c'est horrible à
des bassins moment oui alors elle s'en
remet à singer les membres du jury
essaie de deviner quelles stars et sous
le costume c'est tout voilà l'intérêt du
programme
le souci c'est qu'il pense tous à des
stars de dallas il donne des noms font
frère et chaque semaine vous allez dire
ah non deux
et chaque semaine faire tu vas voir que
c'est un autre bail quoi ce format le
même délire quoi regarder derrière ses
costumes faits avant les gens comme des
victoires de la musique colle c'est
zarko et des oscars
je ne sais pas un joueur de foot ça fait
passionnant
didier deschamps didier deschamps photo
marie lafrance d'évidence et carla bruni
tout le monde passe un truc à ce
moment-là audrey tautou quoi vraiment
mais vraiment ça que j'ai pensé à
laisser ce lia sarkozy à cécilia sarkozy
pense que vous êtes peut-être noémie
lenoir grande élégante mal qu'un connu
du monde entier
[Musique]
ouais
le champion colin field à l'étude
m
j'étais fou rire parce qu'on ne connaît
pas c'est une immense championne maria
dos des grecs selon moi que des pays
font tuer si je mettrais ma main dans le
jury est là qu ils savaient pas qui
c'est sûr et actif il a laissé nadal
gasquet malade toi qui m'a vu il s'est
dit si c'est les mecs dans la forêt
d'art kck une énorme d'arc a aussi c'est
qu'il ya julien doré aussi quatre idées
parce qu'ils ont ils aidé non 12 oui
c'est à dire est ce que j'ai une gueule
en fut un coup sous la normale et il
fait la vanne parce que dans son clip il
est des guides l'air et tursac le cdr
est bien lui livrer ben ouais mais vous
voyez vraiment audrey tautou cécilia
sarkozy est allé se déguiser on aime nos
frères et elle va peut-être justement
parce que les américaines jouent le jeu
il ya une vraie star joe les américains
et chez nous le prenne pour que les ils
veulent pas jouer le jeu et ça ça rend
des émissions n'ya pas les grandes stars
qu'on aimerait que ça va jouer au jeu
après mêlée pendant cette saison la
journée c'était à metz alors dans
l'extrait qu'on vient de voir
on sent qu au moment où il découvre
marie josé pérec allard moment de
malaise des gens qui la reconnaissent
pas tout de suite
on sait pas tout de suite ah ouais c'est
marie josé pérec tu as en exclusivité on
a les images de la personne qui parle
dans l'oreillette de notre canal regarde
autour de soi
allez
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
camille sée marie josé pérec marie jo
pérec et faisait ch sauvage et du sport
je crois voilà médaille olympique triple
championne
la déprime mal
vous met des gens connus aussi inscrit
plus simple à côté mais bon là pour
l'accueillir à 10 à 20 ans il va trouver
que c'est marie josé pérec frères des
mois en faut être dans le costume avec
elle très haut alors on a pu voir aussi
dans l'émission la prestation de l'aigle
vous avez donné votre premier dans un
étang et j'ai pas pu m'empêcher de faire
un rapprochement avec un moment culte de
tpm pays regardez
[Applaudissements]
voilà
merci ma lancée
[Applaudissements]
concert concert le 4 août et on m'a dit
que c'était moi le pendant amateur mdr
mais non j'ai déjà fait la chouette
j'adore le livre de la vallée phase i
avec moi je vous jure c'est vraiment un
mais grand malheur parce que je la kiffe
dames après les traînards cas au delà
des gens qui sont avec moi je m'en bats
les steaks autant elle france pour la
promo de masse singer tf1 a mis les
mascottes dont des programmes de la
chaîne comme la météo ou encore danse
avec les stars
mais ils sont allés encore plus loin ils
ont fait la promotion de l'émission
pendant la cérémonie du 11 novembre
je crois que la star sous le costume ou
regarder ces raquel garrido gains
l'éphéméride du jour eh bien nous fêtons
pas du jour de demain théodore ce samedi
avec encore quelques minutes de clarté
en moins ah mais non c'est trop tôt et
non d'abord il ya le journal d'anne
claire coudray ensuite 20 heures le mag
et on vous retrouve évidemment en
massinga je vais lire joie attendait
qu'est ce c'est que ce truc c'est le
pense à le penser ma singer mais ces
studios ses lacets 217 c'est vous c'est
219 c'est à côté puis c'est demain soir
ma singer 21h fils est là bas on n y
avait cette décision il ya eu cette
décision d'avoir un lieu commémoratif
qui est très symbolique parce qu'on le
verra à l'image ce sont six militaires
français de différent
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
les prestations dans un instant mais
vous pensez s compagnie ça va être dur
il faisait que ça va durer ou pas et
eric naulleau le dieu de ça il ya un
problème de public parce que si c'est
attractif pour les gosses marie josé
pérec pour l'ego c'est vraiment une
immense championne a gagné mais ça ne
leur dira rien du tout sourire quand ils
vont voir david douillet où c'est plus
ton ami qui avait dans le casting est
liée au yo yo ichi life
oui il n'a reconnu d'autres qui vont
sans doute pas les enfants pas dans le
pied dans le panda je pense non non il
al séni les palais et maisons qui est
pas là je crois pas j'ai pas entendu
bilal assadi je crois que l on reparle
ben écoute on en parle oui non mais peu
importe c'est samedi soir c'est un
programme absolument familiale les
enfants absolument adoré c'est vendredi
c'est ça me dispenser samedi soir c'est
vendredi c'est vendredi soir pardon
programme familial les enfants adorent
et sur les réseaux sociaux vous sais pas
si vous avez regardé les gens sont pris
au jeu
c'était absolument incroyable et il se
répondaient il disait moi je pense que
ces machins ah non mais moi j'ai tout je
pense que truc et c est moi je crois
réellement que peu importe qu'il y à
l'intérieur on voit participer à la fête
et le mécanisme est plutôt malin la
mécanique est plutôt maline puisque s'il
n'y a qu'une seule révélation par
émission donc on va quand même resté
malgré tout et peu importe si les
révélations sont peut-être décevant pour
les uns ce qu'on va quand même se dire
attends je vais quand même aller voir le
vendredi prochain
si celui qui est dans le prochain pour
savoir que c'est une stratégie on va
voir toujours les mêmes des mêmes
costumes et 2 à la fin les mecs
une fois que tu as vu que c'était marie
josé pérec et philippe boost au nez dans
le frère un moment tu leur salaire c'est
la nikon qui a ouvert le bal de masse
singer avec une reprise de beyoncé voilà
par ou la semaine prochaine on va voir
que lundi comme c'est marie-france me
toucha voilà
l'avenir ne peut pas meloni
rires
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
julie zenatti à part le panda c'est
julie zenatti semaines encore par des
analystes
il faut pas que ce soit là sont pas dire
façon on sait qu'il ya plein de gens qui
on verra bien je connais le nez quand
s'agit paraît que dans l'ani corps n'y
paraît on en a on va parler de philippe
risotto c'est philippe risotto il a
toujours une voix douce et fait des
caracos j'ai avec lui oui non ou la
poche et on était en train de discuter
entre nous qui pouvait être la licorne
tout que la mécanique fonctionne j'ai
une seule réserve c'est que c'est long
et c'est effectivement le fait que ce
soit pas en direct
coupe un petit peu même si le dispositif
français obligatoire c'est un beau coup
un petit peu décevant mais moi je j'aime
beaucoup le principe
géraldine à moi j'ai trouvé ça malaise
tv j'ai trouvé ça long laborieux
vraiment alors d'abord quel combal que
j'adore qui est sans doute le plus
talentueux en tout cas sur tf1 je trouve
qu'il a l'air perdu sauf sur tf1 c'est
peu talentueux où les pères mais il va
tracer nikos alors on y arrive et me
dire en bref vous ne connaîtrez mal à
lèvres et doudou géant le jury le jury
pardon mais il est complètement
décrédibilisée panda gauche carla bruni
et audrey tautou enfin franchement ça
reçues avant le truc complètement moi
j'ai adoré camille je vous dis la vérité
mais le juriste footnote d'uranium et
qu'il est ridicule arrêtez vous savez
très bien que c'est pas audrey tautou
brad pitt a répondu à nos regards
étaient trop la série dit chez moi aussi
en plus j'ai voilà les aime bien pour la
plupart de 2,2 sur quatre les aime bien
là et bah franchement voilà hélary josé
pérec ici fait dire à chaque fois le
wikipedia en urgence pour savoir qui
c'est au moins montré en situation
montré une course de manière sûre et
pourtant réapprennent un truc mais
voulait pas payer la course on se verra
rien j'ai les mêmes problèmes j'ai les
mêmes problèmes que j'ai regardé avec
des jeunes les jeunes ils ont été très
déçu par l'issue m'arrive bien sûr on
sait qui on regardera pas la semaine
prochaine c'est ce que m'ont dit aussi
dévalé des enfants de gagner gros succès
quand on regarde juste là la courbe
après la première coupure pub
il ya une grosse chute oui mais bon je
pouvais mais non car ça va ça va ça va
durer mais pas à ce niveau là d'accord
boîtier millions 6 et s'attendait à
tweaks la vraie c'est camille combal
pour faire durer le programme trois
heures comme ça c'est impossible avec le
suspense il délai il délègue mais c'est
très dur le jury et je peux pas vous
mais moi il me saoule ils sont gentils
aliments fruits et il se [ __ ] de notre
gueule
arrêtez de sortir cécilia sarkozy est à
venir à cannes il avait alors la
promesse de vente des trucs aussi je le
redis valais nous va voir ta grand-mère
raison valable si la carrière alessandra
est aussi annoncé peut-être que les gens
chez eux sont pas sont peut-être la vie
de rêver peut-être qu'ils se disent ah
c'est vrai ça se trouve il ya eu fini
dans le costume moi je sais mais
peut-être que les gens y croient et il
va pas vous êtes un ami de cavada il
vous a pas dit qu'il allait faire cette
émission alors ce n'est plus mon ami
samedi soir dans son ami samedi soir la
cérémonie des habitants ça n'est pas mon
ami syndicat michel dans le métier ça va
très vite
[Rires]
21e cérémonie des nrj des efforts
attendez on va voir déjà ce qu'on
pensait jean marc singer will 49 % et 51
pour espérer passer millions ça va
baisser mais on verra ça